[Applause]
absolutely spectacular had you been
planning that thinking about that where
that comes from
i just decided you know what i was gonna
[Applause]
we got an opportunity to get on the
stage and take a photo man at that big
moment at 75 tell me how that felt and
tell me what your did you vision
yourself being on that stage in 25 years
uh you know it's an honor uh just to be
a part of that you know i've seen so
many so many great players you know the
best that will play the game uh you know
get honored here tonight and uh me just
being a part of it is a blessing man and
you know hopefully in 25 years i'll be
you know sharing that stage with you
guys
this is reggie
i'm begging i'm pleading
please
please next year if they're going to
have that dark contest it's the final
event you've got to be a please
please please please you would bring
down the house
for sure because i don't think the 10
foot run high though
and you know what i agree with what we
said i agree